ils sont près de cinquante mille à
disparaître chaque année la disparition
de marion wagon il s'agit d'une jeune
fille qui a disparu elle est âgée de 9
ans des enfants qui se volatilisent dans
la nature et qui laissent des parents
anéantis fuit plus en plus désemparé je
ne sais pas si officiels sont vivantes
enlèvement fut mauvaise rencontre
les cas de figure sont nombreux ah si
les forces de l'ordre se mobilisent les
recherches n'aboutissent pas toujours
c'est le combat que mène samira el mahi
depuis un an et demi
leur petite fille wissem a disparu le 31
juillet 2019 alors qu'elle se rendait
sur son lieu de travail près de villabé
dans l'essonne
depuis pas un jour ne passe sans que ses
parents ne la cherche et aucune piste
n'est laissé au hasard
ce soir samir aït-saïd ans un appel sur
notre plateau pour retrouver wissem
merci d'être avec nous c'est mireille
merci marie mot sabrina il m'a dit merci
d'être là ça fait un an et demi
maintenant pousser votre fille a disparu
c'était le 31 juillet 2019 à la saison
vous habitez à evry courcouronnes dans
l'essonne ce matin à 7 heures du matin
il part de chez elles de chez vous non
pour se rendre à son travail elle est
apprentie esthéticienne dans un institut
de beauté à quelques kilomètres de chez
vous et elle n'y est jamais arrivée tout
talent la première question
tout le monde va se dire déjà
actuellement où avait été avertie
qu'elle a et j'avais été arrêté à son
travail
j'ai été averti par son employeur vers
les coups de 16 heures nous alors vers
les coups de 16 heures
donc vous apprenez que sont pas par son
patron qu'elle n'est jamais arrivé avec
l'application de géolocalisation sur le
portable de wissem vous apprenez qu'elle
aurait pris la direction du nord de
l'île de france c'est c'est à bezons cas
borné son téléphone pour la dernière
fois vers 10 heures du matin
est ce que vous savez pourquoi les
belles serait parti a besoin ou pas du
tout donc deux ans à 50 kilomètres de
notre domicile d'accord donc quelques
jeux les quelques jours qui ont suivi on
a on a consulté en fait son estime
téléphoniques et on a su qu'elle était
avec un en contact avec un garçon sur
snap d'accord que ce gars ce fameux
garçon il aurait donné rendez vous donc
à s'est rendu à ce rendez vous d'après
ses dires ils ont mangé ensemble au
mcdonald's d'accord il dit qu'il est
parti s'acheter un survêtement au
décathlon qui l'a laissée au mcdonald's
et que quand il est revenu assez pour
l'utiliser
donc c'est incroyable cette histoire
alors à ce moment-là on perde
définitivement la trace de votre fille
tout à fait ça dure maintenant depuis
plus de 18 mois
18 mois de recherche aucune nouvelle ok
nous 1/2 cm s'est jamais reconnecter
aucun ne s'est jamais les tous les
garçons et filles m'ont prenez bien il
est 20 heures 16 on dirait que ça veut
dire que ses parents
du jour au lendemain plus de nouvelles
de votre fille comment quelles étaient
vos rapports
ce qu'il ya plein de gens qui vont
demander voilà ce que vous étiez fâché
est ce que vous étiez très bons rapports
et samedi tout ça se passait bien
quoi tu joueras du tout à m'appeler sa
maman chérie donc on était fusionnelle à
vous après tout le temps aussi au
téléphone tout le temps ça fait toujours
mal était exactement tout le temps on
était en contact et du jour au lendemain
c'est comme si j'ai reçu en fait une vif
donc je vois maintenant voilà il ya des
commentaires à l'été en embrouille
quand vous dites c'est pas du tout le
cas donc là du tout vraiment y'a juste
jamais eu de notre premier appareil vous
aussi on pas au pape a levé vous êtes
étiez voilà très proche d'elle
et jamais il n'y a pas une dispute le
non non pas du tout
c'était pas une enfant rebelle c'était
pas quelqu'un qui qui était contrôlée
par y avait pas de dispute en fait c'est
quelqu'un de très calme alors au départ
vous commencez vous même l'enquète cette
affaire vous découvrez comment de sa
disparition comme vous l'avez dit un
jeune homme appelle wissem ils sont
allés sont vus donc ils ont été mangé
dans un fast-food ensuite mis sa version
c'est que il a été chercher un
il a été acheté un jogging et qu'il est
revenue elle n'était pas elle n'était
plus là depuis ou mettez toute notre
énergie à retrouver votre fille
distribué des tracts placarder des
photos de votre fille vous reculiez de
nombreux témoignages nous la question
tournoi se poser ici s'est il faut on
dit quoi la police mais c'est vrai que
mine de rien on se dit il ya peut-être
eu
il faut peut-être y est on a pris un
avocat comme tous les parents c'est la
première fois que ça nous arrive donc
vous êtes complètement paumés ou sait
pas vers où on sait pas justement donc
on a tardé à prendre un avocat
donc on a pris un avocat au mois de mars
d'accord suivant et une à une
instruction a été ouverte
donc on a un juge d'instruction qui
s'occupe de l'enquète mais ils disent
quoi au niveau de l' enquête ils en sont
à déposer plainte pour enlèvement et
séquestration
d'accord ils ont déjà rien dit field
avec elle comment ils ont vu le jeune
homme qui est avec elle on sépare été
interrogé une première fois d'accord et
on sait pas qu'elle est là la suite
alors nous dit rien on nous dit que
c'est le secret de l'instruction
est-ce que vous avez finalement accès
aux vidéos des caméras surveillance du
mcdo non on n'a jamais pu y avoir accès
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on a demandé
c'était trop tard
déjà le dossier de wissem a été pris en
charge un mois et demi après mes deux
petites histoires à moi à argenteuil le
commissariat qui s'occupait de la faire
on n'a même pas eu de contact on n'a
même pas daigné nous recevoir
alors qu'ils étaient 50 bornes pour
aller au commissariat et on nous a
jamais reçus et vous disais quoi ça mais
on ne nous a rien donné donc vous allez
voir le comédien vous dit ma fille à
distance vous dit quoi on dépose plainte
pour disparition inquiétante
et alors on suit fig le dossier est
enregistrée et pendant un mois on n'a
pas de nouvelles
je lui avais dans la grande majorité des
dossiers de disparitions d'enfants
hélas pour vous on pense d'abord que
c'est une fugue juillet donc mais au
début sinon ça enquêté il ya eu beaucoup
de temps perdu
et quand vous avez été entre guillemets
pris au sérieux on a vu que c'était une
disparition inquiétante
tout le temps de l'enquète était déjà
perdue donc là maintenant il essaye
effectivement le juge d'instruction
travail
il est c'est un juge d'instruction qui
ne parlent pas ni à la presse ni à vous
on peut le regretter mais il semble
travailler mais est ce que le temps
perdu peut être rattraper parce que à ma
connaissance ils n'ont encore aucune
piste c'est ça qui est incroyable c'est
qu'il ya pas de voie là il n'a pas été
rattrapé les caméras sont devenus
inexploitables oui et qui frappe c'est
un coin incroyable je vous dis aux
ivoiriens de choses qui vont des bras on
va vous raconter la suite de la faire
c'est fou nicolas pernikoff de pardon
question mais au dessus donc disparu le
31 juillet qu'est ce que vous faites le
jour même vous allez être servis oui la
voir la police je vais sur place ma
femme m'appelle je démarre je travaille
dans le 91 j'ai démarré directement dans
95 parce que sur le tous les téléphones
ce que je tiens à préciser sur tous les
téléphones
on peut les géolocaliser ses intégré
dedans d'accord donc c'est pas moi qui
ai mina pitch tient le signaler parce
que j'ai reçu beaucoup de l'insultent
tous les téléphones je perds mon
téléphone je tape mon mot de passe et
mon adresse mail mais je sais pas j'ai
laissé ici c'est inclus dans le
téléphone c'est pas le pape allemand
kabambi une application géolocalisée
j'ai démarré direct j'ai cherché jusqu'à
minuit à un moment je me suis rien une
heure du matin on a et on s'est dirigé
vers le commissariat est donc au
commissariat il s'est passé quoi ils ont
pris ma plainte en août en disparition
inquiétante
ouais ça s'est arrêté là où ils
émettaient encore où ils étaient ils
étaient tous d'accord
jokari c'est comme si le téléphone en
fête a été détruit donc une gamine de 16
ans quand son téléphone j'avais essayé
de savoir si elle avait changé de pays
si elles avaient ils ont fait des
enquêtes dans les aéroports dans les
allées signalés dans les aéroports donc
mais depuis qu'il est là c'est trop tard
bah oui c'est un mois après il ya plus
de caméras il a gardé toutes vos applis
que vous avez eu des retours oui demain
réguler alors on a eu ce qu'on avait ce
qu'on l'avait vu ce que votre fille a
été vue quelque part oui des gens
semblaient l'avoir vu mais quand on a
vérifié les pistes non c'était pas elle
donc à l'heure actuelle depuis 18 mois
c'est pas si elle est encore en vie ou
pas c'est grave c'est incroyable ce
qu'il faut savoir et c'est
malheureusement le cas en général quand
elle va atteindre sa majorité vous savez
qu'elle allait à la 18 ans le 13 février
elle aurait fêté s'il va la sortir du
fichier des personnes recherchées me
suis renseignée par rapport
et non il me dit que malema ils m'ont
gardé en mars dernier plus d'un an après
la disparition et non faire seulement
une information judiciaire pour
enlèvement et séquestration est ouverte
pour l'instant
gilles vous avez enquêté ya rien de
nouveau hélas à deux fils sur la fère
non parce que effectivement le retard
les cannes
tout ça s'est perdu et il n'y a pas de
témoignages réels c'est ça vous avez eu
des fausses pistes mais y'a pas un
témoignage réel
vous avez bien sûr parler à ses amis
mais il n'y a pas quelqu'un qui a pu
dire aux parents voilà on pense que ou
peut-être qu'elle était perdue ou
peut-être qu'un ami peut-être que
quelqu'un y a rien c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire c'est cette jeune fille
font pas des lacs c'est incroyable
incroyable moi j'oublie
il ya plein de gens il ya plein de
réactions il ya plein de gens qui disent
et c'est pas un reproche un média
planner est ce pourquoi vous n'avez pas
été plus vite même dans les rues après
les gens n'ont pas été plus vite
pourquoi la police n'a pas été plus vite
parce qu on a fait vous avez fait ce
qu'il fallait bien fait de leur salaire
pourquoi ça n'a pas suivi derrière enfin
pour eux tout adolescent de 15 16 ans
pour eux c'est qu'on soit là déjà il
fume de six mois on a 18 mois
mais bon je me dis voilà donc maintenant
que la sphère est entre les mains d'un
juge ils prennent les choses au sérieux
pour eux c'est vraiment un enlèvement
une séquestration on parle plus de fugue
d'alors vous avez cru me retrouver dans
un réseau de prostitution dans la région
lyonnaise
c'est à dire sous bois ou dans une
communauté voilà de gens du voyage ou un
peu partout en france vous avez fait des
recherches là dessus c'est non oui on a
fait des recherches
d'accord on a été jusqu'à placer nous
mêmes des caméras dans un restaurant par
les enquêteurs on a fait des recherches
on a 1000 enquête jamais dit que c'est
vous qui trahissez si à la mode de la
police c'est oui non mais on se doit de
bouger c'est notre enfant qui est perdue
quelque part je pense que n'importe quel
parent c'est normal assure frais la mer
mais que vous fassiez bull enquête c'est
incroyable je vous dis la vérité mais
c'est la police et même là c'est des
caméras avec l'autorisation du
restaurateur qui était de bonne foi
quand on a la caméra a pris la jeune
fille s'était pas notre fille à
l'oreille à lyon c'était c'était une
piste de la police pareil quand on a
remonté les caméras bhl s'était pas oui
ça vous croyez qu'elle est ou votre
fille vous avez vous avez vraiment non
est ce que vous y croyez encore vous y
croyez il faut gagner l'espoir
et de grâce à vous si rin et a beaucoup
de témoignages qui remontent pas ce
qu'elle dit que vous faites du buzz
c'est pas du tout c'est moi qui vous ai
sollicité je serai pas là donc c'est pas
votre but vous ne m'avez tendu la main
je vous en remettre moi je suis pire
qu'une chose c'est moi je suis là parce
que je garde espoir jeudi au palais
sarde
donc c'est pas non plus pour ma sait
jamais si willem ou quelqu'un qui a vu
oui c'est la personne qu'il a toutes les
personnes malades tient exactement là on
va aller jusqu'au bout et on
n'abandonnera pas notre fille donc si
cette personne nous en tant qu' la
relâche donc vous n'êtes pas là en fait
vous êtes persuadé que oui allez
retourner quelques pas ma fille ne peut
pas couper les ponts comme ça avec c'est
marrant avec qui c'était incroyable vous
rendez compte
et vous savez j'ai beaucoup de remontées
de parents qui ont subi la même chose
c'est une maman ce matin qu'ils
m'appellent sa fille a été séquestrée
pendant cinq ans une gamine de 10 ans
qui se promenait dans la rue à qui on a
offert des bonbons qui a été emmenée par
un homme qui a été séquestrée pendant
cinq ans mais c'est donc pas là on donc
ça n'arrive pas qu'aux autres les
parents sinon humeur d'arrêt chaque
année s'ils le faisaient de même je ne
vois pas tout ça quand on n'est pas
dedans
voilà je suis en italie voient toujours
ça arrive comme ça on n'y croit pas on
est une famille normale surtout le monde
comme ceux qui nous regardent
voilà on avait une vie tout à fait
pépère et du jour au lendemain vallat ne
s'en font des votes votre histoire elle
est incroyable jeu
j'espère qu'une chose samira hill maïs
et qu' on puisse faire avancer les
choses ce soir grâce à votre
intervention
j'espère que ce sera en poste on sait
que sur les réseaux sociaux et voilà la
mission ou des missions qui regardent et
qu'au bout j'ai qui est très regardé
donc ce soir je voulais absolument que
vous soyez là soit on m'avait sollicité
comme vous l'avait dit et on veut vous
aider
là dessus c'est vrai et c'est de faire
un maximum pour retrouver wissem donc on
fera tous nous aussi pour relayer toutes
les gens à l'humanité de ceux qui nous
regardent charte âgées si vous avez de
la personne mais malte et nous s'il ya
une personne
ils étaient 1,8 c'est mon appel aussi
elle son humanité tout à fait et
regardez la détresse de cette farce du
mac
voilà désormais une famille qui est en
souffrance vous vivez plus là une petite
soeur et un petit frère derrière moi
franchement s'il n'y avait pas mes deux
enfants derrière je crois que je serai
pas debout
donc je tiens parce que j'ai deux autres
enfants derrière je dois te dire pour je
dois tenir pour wissam et pour mes deux
autres enfants
mailly vous arrivez à travailler à
reprendre le travail parce que je sais
que vous aussi vous êtes très très très
atteints bien sûr c'est normal que tu te
faisais tu sais le travail
j'ai beaucoup été non mais je sais que
wissam et et très très émue et que
c'était très difficile pour lui aussi
devenir ce soir oui ça m'ira ça nous
fait il a du mal à pas mêlé en soutien
on est là on est là et on tient pour
miss m
tu as promis mais ma vie je sais qui
mais sa nuit de travail des inconnus
nous ont épaulés le collègue de travail
mon agence des gens qu'on connaît il ya
quand même une solidarité qui se créent
les gens qu'on connaissait même pas
qu'ils nous ont tendu la main et donc
c'est je l'en remercie
ils se reconnaîtront moi en tout cas je
voulais vous remercier vous aussi et
vous tire un grand coup de chapeau parce
que je trouvais exemplaires tous les
deux voilà je voulais vous le dire et
voilà vous vous êtes exprimés sur vous
avez dit ce que vous aviez à dire
franchement je vous dis je pense qu'on a
tous envie de vous aider encore plus ce
soir j'espère qu'on va faire bouger les
choses
je vous dis pas qu'on va y arriver mais
on va tout faire pour et c'est très
important pour moi de vous avoir ce soir
avec nous s'est réjoui nous raconter
votre histoire parce que ça n'arrive pas
qu'aux autres
non c'est à savoir aller un autre garde
chez n'importe quelle famille et giuly
j'espère qu'on va retrouver wissem et
j'espère que même au niveau des services
de police au niveau de la justice
j'espère que cette émission va faire
peut-être bouger les choses et que ça
ils essaieront de mettre voilà plus de
moyens encore pour retrouver wissem
merci merci vous avez une dernière chose
à dire mailly ou samira pas si notre
fille nous voit ben on l'aiment
voilà on n'abandonnera pas bon lâchement
parcours à la rive
vous avez bien raison je prends c'est
bien région ne lâchait pas merci samira
et maïs et riz dont vous n'hésitez pas à
me contacter et quand vous voulez quand
on se
toujours là pour vous aider merci
beaucoup merci à samir aita il vraiment
peu de jambes pour les disperser
c'est incroyable de témoigner comme ça
et le courage qui est dur c'est au
départ en d'exposer en fait la nation
ouais mais on est là c'est très
courageux ce que vous avez fait ce soir
voilà je voulais vous le dire si
forcément reçu merci beaucoup